felizmente para la reputación del
asteroide b612
un dictador turco obligó a su pueblo
bajo pena de muerte a vestirse a la
europea
el astrónomo repitió su demostración en
1900 gente con un traje muy elegante y
esta vez todo el mundo compartió su
opinión
lo que verdaderamente hace que la gente
pobre no acceda a puestos de
responsabilidad no es la falta de
recursos económicos es la falta de
palabras porque la falta de dinero es
coyuntural sin embargo la falta de
palabras es estructural tanto es así que
si a mí me toca la lotería por ejemplo
paso enseguida a tener dinero sin
embargo si yo no tengo palabras mis
hijos tampoco las tendrán de tal manera
que se tardará varias generaciones en
conseguir que esa situación se revierta
hola me llamo fernando soriano y vengo a
hablar de la brecha lingüística y en
concreto quiero explicar de qué manera
la brecha lingüística impide ese ascenso
social para ello voy a partir de la
siguiente frase la siguiente cita en
este caso de samuel johnson que dijo el
lenguaje es el vestido de los
pensamientos y al respecto les hago la
siguiente reflexión si yo he visto de
una manera elegante mis palabras parecen
más importantes pero si mi lenguaje
es más elegante mis ideas también lo
parecerán eso lleva a que siempre en
todos los casos las personas que tienen
una forma de expresarse elegante
consigan posicionar mejor sus ideas y
para ejemplificar esto quiero contarles
algo que me pasó hace pocas semanas yo
suelo formar equipos de debate en
concreto estudiantes de bachillerato
trabajo en un centro muy bueno con
alumnos muy buenos y tenía un equipo al
que estuve formando algo así como tres
meses la noche antes del torneo para un
rato antes casi ya de dar por cerrado el
entrenamiento nos llama el organizador y
nos dicen que podemos inscribir a otro
equipo que pueden ir dos equipos y
entonces lo que hacemos nosotros es
llamar a cuatro chicos sin preparación
para que vayan al mismo torneo que otros
cuatro que se habían formado durante
meses y se me ocurrió hacer el siguiente
experimento les dije ya que vosotros no
vais formados porque no habéis tenido
tiempo para preparar el torneo voy a
poneros una americana
parecida al traje que llevo en el día de
hoy entonces llevaba un equipo el que se
había preparado más con una camiseta de
algodón y un equipo que se había
preparado escasas horas
vestidos con una americana en el caso de
los chicos con vestidos de fiesta en el
caso de las chicas con zapatos caros en
todos los casos el equipo de las
americanas quedó por delante del equipo
mejor preparado y eran de la misma edad
del mismo centro yo era el profesor de
todos pero la manera de vestir
condicionó de manera decisiva la forma
en la que se recibió su discurso y
fíjense si esto lo ampliamos a otros
contextos yo estudié en un colegio del
que salió un presidente del gobierno
pongo un ejemplo de ayer en el ensayo de
los ponentes de esta charla ted tenía a
mi lado a un compañero otro ponente que
había nacido en la misma ciudad que yo
empezamos a hablar de donde habíamos
estudiado cada uno y los ojos éramos del
mismo colegio eso no es casualidad
imaginen un teatro
a mí me pasó mi primer grupo cuando
empecé a dar clases en un pueblo en este
caso de cádiz en una localidad deprimida
socioeconómicamente fuimos a un teatro
en el colegio de la salle de jerez en la
frontera en el momento en el que mis
alumnos entraron en aquel teatro todos
los chicos de la salle se giraron y los
miraron con desprecio no fue solo por la
manera de vestir fue por la manera de
expresarse por la manera en la que no
sabían adecuarse a la situación si tú
estudias en un lugar que te enseña esa
manera podrás acceder a los puestos de
responsabilidad sin embargo si no lo
haces la pobreza vendrá determinada para
ti y para tus hijos por lo menos dos
generaciones
y fíjense de esta manera los ricos
podemos afirmar tienen una manera que
hace captar mejor nuestra atención que
hacen quizás monopolizan a veces más el
tiempo de la conversación a veces te
matizán mejor lo que quieren decir a
veces seleccionan mejor lo que quieren
contar a veces utilizan un tono un tono
una pausa
en ciertos entornos no se enseña a los
chicos a hablar con pausa y esa pausa
gana una entrevista de trabajo la pierde
esa pausa gana un torneo de debate o lo
pierde y esa pausa condiciona la pobreza
evidentemente decía a chomsky que cuando
nosotros cumplimos una cierta edad
perdemos la capacidad para aprender
lenguas nuevas pienso por ejemplo
michael robinson uno de los héroes de mi
infancia que nunca logro nunca ha
logrado aprender español de manera
perfecta porque intento aprender español
siendo ya mayor de una cierta da ahora
mi afirmación es la siguiente y si
tampoco el registro pudiera aprenderse
una vez que cumplimos una cierta edad y
si una vez que aprendemos ya de mayor es
un registro ya no encajamos en ese
registro porque claro nosotros hablamos
por ejemplo de los nuevos ricos o
hablamos por ejemplo de los judíos
conversos hablamos de gente que nunca
fueron capaces de separarse de esa
estela comunicativa que llevaba su
discurso
y fíjense del mismo modo les hablo de
los nuevos ricos pero eso ya aparecía en
el satiricón en roma y por ejemplo en la
cultura francesa se usa la expresión
pero saben ustedes cuál es mi teoría en
realidad la aristocracia utilizaba la
etiqueta de nuevos ricos para impedir
que la burguesía fuera como ellos podrás
tener mucho dinero pero nunca serás como
yo y porque no serás como yo pues no
serás como yo porque nunca hablaras como
yo
la diferencia entre los nuevos ricos y
la aristocracia era la brecha
lingüística era la brecha comunicativa
era esa manera que se tiene o no se
tiene y esa brecha cambia el mundo
porque hay clases sociales pero hay
también clases lingüísticas de hecho hoy
por ejemplo me he puesto una corbata de
diferir que en mi casa en harrypotter
esta corbata hace que yo cuando hable se
me escucha mejor un poco como la
serpiente del principito en cierto modo
claro yo al quitarme la corbata también
hago que el discurso suene en cierto
modo diferente pero si pensamos en
cuentos ya que hablábamos antes de
educación
vladimir propp decía que todos los
cuentos tienen un esquema que viene a
repetirse una y otra vez pienso por
ejemplo en la cenicienta fíjense en el
esquema
chica de buena familia después seguida
de su rango que va al pueblo
se educa con la plebe una serie de años
pero ella era de las reales y el
príncipe un día de casualidad la
encuentra
la cenicienta mi teoría es que el
príncipe no era fetichistas lo que pasa
es que el príncipe es la reconocido por
su manera de hablar porque ocurre lo
mismo se expresaba como alguien de la
aristocracia
y esta mañana ha sido esta mañana estaba
buscando un contraejemplo y me acordé de
sherezade yo pensaba que sherezade
rompía mi teoría porque dios sherezade
la de dos mil y una noches' consiguió
acceder a la élite económica en el
relato gracias a poder hablar bien a
poder relatar historias de una manera
adecuada que la hacían parecer nobles mi
intuición filológica me dijo que era
buena idea buscar el último de sherezade
sherezade significa la que tiene
apariencia noble la que tiene apariencia
noble
y claro de ahí llegó a tal vez la cita
queda un poco hilo conductor a toda esta
charla se la escucha a juan mata por
primera vez él decía que la manera en la
que los padres le hablan a los niños
condiciona plenamente su éxito académico
en el futuro de tal manera que si un
chico escucha menos palabras escucha
nombrar a las realidades de normas de
formas más sencillas puede ocurrir que
al final el día de mañana pues tenga un
desfase muy grande de millones de
palabras frente a otros chicos de un
entorno cuyos padres no tengan estudios
que no haya tenido la ocasión de
escuchar de tener esos estímulos
monforte hablaba en este caso de un tipo
de feedback que lo que demuestra es que
al final
aprendemos por las correcciones que nos
hacen si nuestro entorno no nos corrige
cuando hablamos no aprenderemos a hablar
mejor y cuando nosotros según ese
feedback auto correctivo recibimos más
correcciones y escuchamos más palabras
conseguimos hablar de esa manera y
vuelvo a lo de siempre no es lo mismo
llevar la americana que no llevar no es
lo mismo hablar con esa pompa que no
hablar así
y fíjense desde esa gramática que cada
hablante crea cada hablante crea su
propia gramática según chomsky llegamos
al debate académico que es creo por lo
que a mí me han traído y aquí era el
motivo original aunque no voy a hablar
demasiado de debate
el debate son cuatro chicos en cada
punta de la sala cuatro hablan a favor
de una cuestión y otros cuatro en contra
es posible que cuatro lleven americana y
quizá cuatro no la lleven
de hecho claro en el torneo que antes
les he explicado pasó eso había cuatro
chicos de mi centro que llevaban
americana y cuatro que nos imagínense el
centro aquel del que yo les decía el del
teatro el centro aquel en el que yo
empecé a trabajar imagínense a esos
cuatro chicos cuatro cualquiera de los
que alborotaban en el teatro enfrente de
chicos del pilar del colegio del pilar
de madrid cuántas opciones hay de que un
empresario les dé un puesto de trabajo a
los míos y claro frente a eso me planteo
podríamos conseguir que el debate
académico en aquellos lugares donde lo
que hacen falta son palabras permita
revertir la brecha social y lingüística
podemos conseguir acabar con las clases
lingüísticas yo pienso que se puede pero
que no se está consiguiendo la mayoría
de los torneos nos ganan centros
privados la mayoría de los oradores de
competición son chicos de familias cuyos
padres tienen niveles de estudios altos
mis alumnos de centros donde trabajamos
donde no tenía esas circunstancias no
llegan a esos torneos de debate por
tanto no conseguimos que sea la
herramienta de promoción social que
debería ser porque yo al final lo que
quiero es en última instancia que
creemos un nuevo código
a ver si hay un código
en el que debatimos y siempre ganan los
mismos tendremos que encontrar un código
diferente porque claro si hacemos debate
académico y siempre en ese debate
académico prima la forma aquellos que
han estudiado en un lugar y tienen unos
padres determinados siempre ganarán y
sin embargo las ideas no se escucharán y
eso no sólo es una pena sino que además
es una gran pérdida para la sociedad que
necesita las ideas de todos no solo las
ideas de aquellos que llevan la
americana pues está claro yo pienso
muchas veces que a lo mejor llevaba una
camisa por dentro o la ayudas por fuera
o hablas de un modo o de otro y tu idea
debería llegar igual pero el problema es
que no solo no llega igual sino que
genera crispación cuando una persona
escucha a otro hablar
si no lo entiende se enfada
en este caso cuando la gente no se
entiende lógicamente discuten y esto me
permite conectarlo con uno de los
grandes ídolos de mi vida que es un
lingüista del que quizá ustedes nunca
hayan oído hablar aunque seguro que sí
conocen su creación el lingüista se
llama luis
zamenhoff luisa mejor fue un lingüista
judío que vivió en sus carnes todo lo
relacionado con la segunda guerra
mundial y entonces él en toda su buena
fe dijo voy a conseguir que la gente
deje de discutir y como la gente discute
porque no se entiende voy a crear una
lengua universal el firmaba sus
artículos bajo el seudónimo doctor
esperanto esperanto significa que tiene
esperanza claro él decía que el doctor
esperanto porque él tenía esperanza la
esperanza de acabar con todas las
guerras de la tierra utilizando la
lengua intentando y consiguiendo que los
pueblos dejaran de discutir por no
entenderse y claro yo pienso que la
lucha de clase
eso es una lucha que se produce porque
la gente no se entiende y que se
evitaría logrando poner la palabra al
alcance de todos porque a veces nos
esforzamos por dar subsidios ayudas por
llevar una serie de medios a todas las
clases sociales pero no solo debemos
llevar medios también necesitamos llevar
palabras sobre todo necesitamos llevar
palabras porque claro si al final yo
simplemente
fazio duscher o te doy tu alimentos
nunca aprenderás a pensar de una manera
compleja
fíjense ustedes
si decía zamenhof que él tenía esperanza
yo me planteo ahora si la tengo
si hay esperanza si hay esperanza para
la princesa pobre del cuento
sinceramente creo que no la hay
sinceramente creo que todo está perdido
sinceramente creo que no vamos a
conseguir revertir la brecha lingüística
y sinceramente les animo a que miren por
la calle ahora cuando salgan y se
plantee en cuanto de la gente que hay
enfrente pertenece a una mitad del mundo
a la otra yo creo realmente que no lo
vamos a lograr creo que el debate no lo
va a conseguir creo que la educación
tampoco y creo que los pobres siempre lo
serán por su manera de hablar realmente
lo creo
y sin embargo
porque no mantener la esperanza
la palabra comunicación encierra dentro
otra que es común sólo hay comunicación
cuando partimos de lo común la única
manera de entendernos es y será siempre
partir de lo común por eso como las
ideas nos unen y las formas nos separan
espero que al final como vehículo del
pensamiento la palabra consiga que esas
ideas nos unan y si no al menos pensar
en zamenhof pensaré en su espíritu y me
diría mismo quizás no lo logremos pero y
si verdaderamente la palabra pudiese
acabar con las brechas económicas del
mundo muchas gracias